COVID PROTOCOL, HE IS ON THE
YK
DID WELL ON THE POWER PLAY IN
THE LAST GAME AGAINST DALLAS IS
DOCS IT BACK TO FOX A, LOOKING
TO GET THAT  BEAUTIFUL
PASS.
SEGUIN'S CHANCE,THE
BROWN, PROTECTS THE PUCK
BEAUTIFULLY, RILEY,  WHAT A
>> Dominic: WE HEARD
JUST ONE SHOT ON GOAL, THE LAST
ALMOST GOT SOME OFFENSE, GOT
THEM BACK, GOES IN FRONT, BACK
AND INTO THE GLOVE OF LINDGREN,
THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY, AND THAT
THE SLOT, IT IS UP TO THE POINT
, THE DEFENSEMAN HAS SPACE TO
GET A SHOT DOWN TO THE NET WHAT
PUT
GUYS THAT HAVE GROWN UP IN A
SIMILAR HOCKEY ENVIRONMENEND TO
BLUES WITH 10.4 TO GO, GOOD
D INSTEAD, THEY GET ABOVE GO FO
TO CLOSE THE DEAL.
20 MINUTES FOR THE STARS
BUCHNEVICH AND ALONE, WAIT,
NEVER GOT THE THERE SEGUIN  IN
FRONT, ONE, THAT
THE GAME TONIGHT, THE REFEREE
OUT WITH COVID PROTOCOL
DAN O'ROURKE HASYOUR?
DOWN
AFTER THIS SAVE.
BUCHNEVICH HAS BARBASHEV,
BARBASHEV, BARBASHEV,
BARBASHEV, NO.
BUCHNEVICH WRAPAROUND, NO.
, HE GETS HIS NIGHT SCHOOL
YEARS, AND THE STARS ARE RIGHT
BACK IN IT WITH 7:49 TO GO, HE
FROM, RIGHT ON THE STICKUP
ROBERTSON.
>> John: SO WE TALK ABOUT GOOD
DURING THE CHRISTMAS SEASON.
TOP, AND THESE RUSSIANSR THE
GOAL H